though he's got six points in seven
points I never gets in his rug sweetie
when he finds capella he throws it down
and he's foul
dream Lee active Jack this guy's done
game passes well who else there gionee
precise position eight she steps over to
help
34 for Vuckovich did woody the lane open
up Beverly with a rebound Beverly on the
attack
[Applause]
that you projected with your Duke
arithmetic Stauskas oh look down put it
down
what's the bow
and you drive it towards the basket
that's going to open a lot of seams I
know this is not a 3-point shot but this
isn't get blocked if the players fine
now and then you get that shot to go
from the corner they can play eight or
nine years in this fella
nice pass four minutes here's good pass
from Tyler Ennis leading Clint to the
basket and Clint with that excellent
[Music]
[Applause]
full extension seven six we talked just
a moment ago about the aggressiveness of
Allen and look where he catches it does
he have to dribble it absolutely not so
it's a good pitch off the floor
[Applause]
Marty lob pass capela oh my goodness
it's gonna be much better when it gets
back out on the court all right Michael
there is a grown man's camp
look at the reach of Jared Allen using
hand to fend off valid unis a little bit
this game with 12 it's the first rebound
here tonight for Houston there's James
take it up I can take a look at this
pick and roll see how they move it out
of the center so that Clinton has a
different angle to the basket and on the
neighbors emergency center Super Bowl
you soon he does catch it with the left
the big going out other four guys will
be switching Harris rejected the rookie
blocks Jared Allen there comes the
challenge here comes the weak side boy
that is just hand on ball times as well
it from 20th was James with 30 points
and 10 assists
look at this past that cliff after he
dunks it he's just barely Hey operate he
knows how to celebrate Alan gives up his
dribble need some help Russell comes to
the ball with six to shoot
bouncing
[Applause]
the front show and the season photos
there's a steal by Harden
going to watch as a sponge starts
[Applause]
the Rockets on a 13-2 two runs
Wow didn't what he lobs it up Oh Jared
Allen Skywalker his play picture-perfect
in would he draw on it Whiteside tosses
it up for Jared Allen and there was a
point in time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wondering why this isn't an n1 right
here when did the fowl occur I mean
that's very close to an n1 they're gonna
count it down they aren't gonna give me
n1 going through the ground one minute
to go Alan Wow check this extension out
by even the silhouette would look Statue
of Liberty yeah there you go love it
it's unbelievable what the Spurs have
done throughout this incredible run
Murray drives all when a block from
capella don't fell a flurry trying to
finish I call that singing that's ha
cappella 14 to shoot they reset the 14
yeah and do pension to former Carolina
oh he assaulted the rim first of all you
love him taking off from the foul line
one dribble from the top of the key
[Music]
[Applause]
in each Bowl
[Music]
three-point line getting some benefit
from their penetration blocked by Allen
off Blake Griffin
dunk cry double-double of the season
here tonight 14 points 10 rebounds
wicked 16 point
but every player top-to-bottom you start
to see is the net builder roster fires
it down with two hands
FAFSA pass from Paris a beautiful job
fake high goes low ISIL ball here Scott
by Williams couldn't finish to pedal
head us back
[Applause]
and the foul finish by Clint capela
leading the Lincoln vehicle percent way
we'll see so additional time because of
the injuries that we brought up Blake
Griffin gets gummed his hands up but
this is the strength
this is the muscle impoverish nine
points of the game in the first quarter
for Houston he's got the first nine here
in the third dropped to capela
[Music]
your head like Shaq would say barbeque
chicken down there watch your words
[Music]
the heart jenny has gums knocks
welcome to the NBA look
Russell tough delivery a beautiful job
was again by Jared Allen droll to the
hoop you that you big man finish stuff
the stat sheet oh yes hundred percent
it's a little big here there that's all
[Applause]
oh great stop and go let's career clean
in this system
[Applause]
[Music]
Dudley drives nice charity
runneth over Jared Dudley with the
penetration and Allen the great teamplay
[Applause]
rejection by cappella Paul Tucker
it's a Lakers get it up the floor in a
hurry James
[Applause]
just got the King push the pace big old
black by Jared Allen all of it
he got all look at that ball there was
no dispute right there Lakers get it in
tore shot Kuzma knocked out of there by
balls four-point deficit save it to 15
most of this crap on his feet capela
trying to make them sit with a - and
finish rocket trying to peddle his way
through traffic here comes the dead of
Cobo with the denial comes up huge
straight up the verticality of John vine
and the second quarter free got the step
[Applause]
I mean between the lines you are City
Miller using the day the screen there's
the bounce in the push ah David he got
Davis cleaned just look at this a flat
pudding that is extremely extremely
tough but only a few players in this
league could probably go do that just to
go and get it both flat-footed well
that's the reason they thought they peed
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foul is called on a three-point
opportunity Chris with a nice pass
rather than either cappella says you
know what pinking did when he was on the
floor with him and then decided not to
dish it out if there was a little power
play oh my goodness chance to check this
out
[Applause]
Gries doesn't know what's coming at what
a beautiful extension that's like Golden
State Territory
[Music]
[Applause]
capella
MCW has to throw it over there he really
has nothing so Clint from ten feet two
dribbles and a power slam just right
through Jared Allen like a pillow beside
a big mammoth hammer from Jenner now
you'd ask him to dunk it when you go up
soft not be more no and he tries to dunk
it every single time and he's got such
good touch and touch around the basket
that often times she would see him try
and use that or use his hook shots but
not anymore when he is near the basket
and could be if he wanted it
Tolleson right up is hard to space
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
reading the defense pointed up there
only capella
and the big fella brings it home now
remember folks that Myles Turner 71 and
cappellas listed at 610 a nice shine
Russell off the mark crew roots thought
he had the offensive rebound young nice
fake around Harris drops it inside
gene but what continues to impress not
just these blocks but his recovery off
of getting to these for the beard we put
some pretty big numbers against the
Nugget pocket back and been an absolute
hammer job by Clint capela so he's a
willing passer great bounce pass into
capela who hammers it's just a great way
to kind of break up your season in the
segment's versus looking at it as like
one daunting with 82-game schedule the
cutter sexton denied by L and the fro
gets the rook there's but look he didn't
learn the first time but he's not
learned second time you don't learn
today young fella you gonna learn if
that is Jared Allen Mason
[Music]
[Applause]
block of the game that's very hakeem
olajuwon like a clique came from the
weak side and erased that one basis
Matthews - Sam big guys take up that
much space now quickly it says he's even
gotten stronger and his ability to
finish rustle the cross
[Applause]
grown man's move to the wrench here
again same play another pick-and-roll
but an earlier pass and he just goes up
and gathers part part of that watch this
watch he's not to blame you see that
almost took the ball away from you now
rivers down the cappella that's the way
to move the basketball harden gets
double-teamed they passed the ball once
twice get a dunk and it gets hit on the
arm good call by the official to see
that as capela with the hammer now 15
the flow with me I think he just does
everything quietly in a way the basket
the reverse row down
[Music]
he said watch this what thanks for the
pass Chris he just took off and said he
Jared Allen attack mode
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
season with 70 or more points in the
first half
[Music]
managers picked up his first personal
foul
approaching need to play good screen
Laverne for the folks in the rent and
out of bounds agos moments ago levert
attacking mb slow rotation and just
throw it to the rim
look at this Venice here by our both
Paul and Harden have to drive they're
not coming to help
[Applause]
the sensational defensive play stopping
what would have been a dunk by Iguodala
as we go down what is mine made
Rick capella says not on my watch
big time block on the dunk attempt
spectacular defense backup help what's
up you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content